vous à tous merci de nous retrouver sur
public sénat le grand paris va-t-il
coûter plus cher que prévu
hier jean paul huchon le président de la
région ile de france a estimé qu'il y
aurait un surcoût de 10 milliards
d'euros
le gouvernement a fait savoir que quand
à lui il attendait le rapport aux années
rapport qui doit permettre une
évaluation du coût de ce projet
d'aménagement des transports en ile de
france
la commission du développement durable
du sénat a de son côté auditionné hier
etienne guyot préfet président de la
société du grand paris un sujet donc
particulièrement d'actualité et c'est
donc cette audition que je vous propose
de suivre tout de suite bonne fin
d'après-midi à tous nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir donc monsieur
etienne guyot qui président du
directoire du grand paris et qui est
évidemment un sujet passionnant de
présenter d'actualité je voudrais dire
aussi que je suis vraiment très heureux
de le recevoir puisque il a sévi dans le
département du gers vous savez que le
département du gers n'est pas le centre
du monde mais bon et que nous avons
partagé ensemble des moments
un fois fort agréable et des moins de
coopération ensuite donc il est passé à
les landes et ensuite il est venu
plus au nord en moselle pour finir donc
à paris où nous l'avons également côtoyé
au ministère de l'aménagement du
territoire est bien sûr toujours avec
lui
cette certitude que nous avons là faire
un grand serviteur de l'état dont les
compétences ne sont plus à rêver
voilà donc monsieur le préfet et
président l'auditoire est de qualité il
est perçu mais parce qu'encore une fois
depuis tout à l'heure depuis 14h nous
sommes à nos éditions 1 sciences mais
bon je pense qu'au fur et à mesure peut
être certaines de nos collègues vont
nous rejoindre
nous écoutons pour nous présenter ce
formidable projet merci beaucoup
monsieur le président de m'accueillir en
cette enceinte je voudrais saluer madame
et messieurs les sénateurs qui sont si
présents vous dire que je suis
accompagné à madrid de pierre allard
chalonnais qui est membre de directoire
de la société du grand paris et je
souhaitais en quelques instants vous
présenter l'état d'avancement du prg de
ceux de ce très grand projet
d'aménagement du territoire
je ne reviendrai pas dans le détail sur
les caractéristiques du projet vous dire
simplement que la carte du schéma
d'ensemble qui vous êtes et distribuer
et faire paraître quatre nouvelles
lignes de métro
trois d'entre elles sont sous maîtrise
de la cité du grand paris la ligne rouge
la ligne bleue et la ligne verte la
ligne orange et sous maîtrise d'ouvragé
du stif au total ce sont plus de 200 km
de nouvelles lignes de métro automatique
représentant 72 nouvelles gares dont 57
sous maîtrise d'ouvragé de la cité du
grand paris qui doivent être créés le
grand paris c'est un projet urbain
social et économique d'intérêt national
qui unit les grands territoires
stratégiques de la région ile de france
et qui s'appuie sur la création d'un
nouveau réseau de transport public de
voyageurs
ce faisant c'est un projet fondamental
pour la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens qu'ils soient de l'île de
france du reste du territoire mais aussi
concernant l'ensemble des étrangers qui
viennent en france
c'est un projet qui va permettre à la
fois d'augmenter l'offre de transport
est également de dé saturer les réseaux
existants la loi grand paris prévoit
également un objectif en visitant
vicieux des créations de 70 mille
nouveaux logements par an un chiffre
pour vous dire à quel point le transport
par rapport à cet objectif logement est
importante dans un rayon de 400 mètres
autour des gares du grand paris express
la manière dont on l'appelle
médiatiquement ce nouveau réseau soit à
dire à 5 minutes à pied dégâts il ya
aujourd'hui 22 millions 500 mille mètres
carrés au sol foncier directement
mobilisables c'est un projet national de
développement
nick sociale par les effets sur
l'attractivité par les gains de
compétitivité par la mise en réseau des
principaux pôles scientifiques
technologiques économiques et culturels
et sportifs d'île de france
l'impact du projet ira bien au-delà de
la simple région capitale c'est un point
important sur lequel nous pourrons
revenir dans le cadre des questions si
vous le souhaitez la société du grand
paris pour ce qui la concerne un rôle
bien particulier sa mission principale
c'est d'abord selon les termes de la loi
de concevoir et d'élaborer le schéma
d'ensemble et les projets
d'infrastructure composant le réseau de
transport public du grand paris et d'en
assurer la réalisation c'est à dire que
nous devons d'abord construire les
tunnels les gares les sites de
maintenance les ateliers ouvrages
annexes
c'est ce qui nous mobilise en priorité
ceux des grands paris a également une
autre compétence elle peut être
aménageurs dans le cadre des contrats de
développement territoriaux c'est à dire
cette nouvelle catégorie de contrat qui
va lier l'état et les collectivités
territoriales créées par la loi et si un
contrat développement territorial
demande à ceux du grand paris d'être
aménageurs elle peut l'être ou en
l'absence de contrats devront
territoriale la société du grand paris
peut-être aménageurs après avis de la
collectivité concernée dans un rayon de
400 mètres
quoi qu'il en soit c'est toujours en
étroite concertation partenariat avec
les collectivités que nous avançons
c'est une marque de fabrique de la sgp à
laquelle nous tenons de façon tout à
fait particulière dans l'accomplissement
de ces deux missions construction d'un
nouveau réseau et aménagement l'as du
grand paris a progressé rapidement au
cours l'année 2012
il faut ajouter que ce n'est que la
seconde année de son existence
il ya deux ans la sgp n'existait pas
elle a progressé selon cette méthode
partenariale dont elle ne s'est jamais
départi le schéma d'ensemble qui est
notre feuille de route a été adoptée à
l'unanimité par le conseil de
surveillance notre conseil descendance
qui rassemble je vous le rappelle non
seulement les représentants de l'état
mais le présent du conseil régional les
présents des conseils généraux et un
maire
de l'île de france pour ce qui concerne
par exemple la détermination de
l'emplacement des gares
eh bien nous avons mis en place pour
pratiquement toutes les gares dont nous
assurons la maîtrise d ouvrage des
comités de pilotage qui réunissent sous
la présidence du maire le co présidence
du maire et citées grand paris
l'intercommunalité le département les
services de l'état le stif les
opérateurs transport et nous avons sont
assis dans la détermination lancement de
l'emplacement souterrain des gars mais
également de l'émergence des gars et
nous aurons terminé à la fin de l'année
2012 de pratiquement déterminé
l'emplacement de toutes les gares de la
société du grand paris
l'accord institutionnel et politique qui
a été signé en janvier 2011 entre l'état
la région et repris par les départements
permet de poursuivre nos travaux dans un
climat tout à fait consensuel partager
absolument indispensable pour ce type
d'investissement stratégique et le
nouveau gouvernement en juin a confirmé
le projet tout le projet le candidat
françois hollande avait eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer pendant la campagne sur
l'intérêt du grand paris et sur sa
nécessaire poursuite
nous sommes donc dans une dynamique qui
est tout à fait positive
je reviens sur quelques éléments de
l'année 2012 pour vous dire ce que nous
avons fait et quelles sont nos
perspectives nous avons installé 2012 la
troisième enceinte de gouvernance de la
cité du grand paris c'est le grand paris
c'est d'abord un conseil de surveillance
présidé par andré santini qui réunit les
élus que je vous ai indiqué il ira
ensuite le directoire
le président votre serviteur qui fait
fonctionner au quotidien la société
et puis il y à un comité stratégique est
une originalité de la loi grand paris
que connaît bien sénateurs que capo
canellas qui réunit l'ensemble des
maires concernés par l'infrastructure
les présidents l'intercommunalité des
représentants de l'assemblée nationale
du sénat les représentants du conseil
est connue sosa régionales et les
représentants les organismes consulaires
donc une assemblée qui aujourd'hui à 120
personnes qui travaillent qui a créé des
groupes de travail sur les gars sur
l'environnement des gars sur la qualité
du service dans le réseau qui va tenir
réunion plénière d'ici quelques jours le
14 décembre prochain qui rendra ses
travaux et ses travaux ont été calés par
rapport aux nôtres de façon alimenter ce
que nous faisons au quotidien c'est une
participation très concrète très
efficace et très utile des élus et de
tous ceux qui sont très proches du
terrain
nous avons également choisi cette année
un architecte conseil qui va nous
conseillez travaillé pendant sept ans
avec nous pour et bien donné les lignes
d'architecturé de design de l'ensemble
des gares du grand paris cet architecte
conseil jacques ferrier travaillera
également avec les architectes qui sont
chargé e de concevoir et de construire
les gars c'est donc un moment très
important parce qu'il faut que les gars
soient à la fois le témoignage de ce que
l'on est dans un réseau également le
témoignage qu'elle reflète la réalité du
terrain la personnalité les
potentialités du terrain et des
territoires dans lesquels elles se
situent naturellement en liaison très
étroite avec les collectivités
territoriales
nous avons mené cette même démarche de
recherche en design architecture pour
les sites de maintenance nous aurons six
sites industriels qui seront des sites
industriels du 21ème siècle qui vont
marquer également le paysage de la
région capitale et nous avons choisi le
cabinet bardonnie wilmore 2012 nous
avons terminé les études préliminaires
qui sont pratiquement achevée à l'été et
surtout lancer les premières
consultations de maîtrise d'oeuvre par
heavy d'appel public à la concurrence
dans le cadre de marchés
les gosses y est c'est marché de
maîtrise d'oeuvre concerne
principalement pour l'instant la ligne
rouge
la ligne rouge sud et notamment le
premier tronçon sur lequel je vais
revenir
l'objectif étant bien évidemment de
déterminer les groupements d'ingénérie d
architecture qui vont nous aider au
stade des études d'avant-projet à
concevoir les gares les tunnels la phase
suivante sera la phase travaux
au total 12 consultations sont en cours
cela représente plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros et ce marché marché
devrait être signé en début d'année
prochaine
nous avons énormément avancé aussi en
termes de concertation depuis la fin du
débat public qui s'est tenu entre
septembre 2010 et janvier 2011 le grand
paris a maintenu un contact très étroit
avec non seulement les élus le public
les associait l'ont fait les entreprises
de quelle manière avançons nous outre
les comités de pilotage gars dont je
vous ai parlé
ces comités qui se sont réunis plusieurs
centaines de fois nous avons réuni en
avril six conférences de tronçons c'est
à dire la réunion de tous les acteurs
d'un tronçon te dire concernés par un
tronçon plus que notre réseau est
découpé en six tronçons donc poursuivi
des contacts très étroits avec deux
milieux économiques par département pour
expliquer avec l'aide des chambres de
commerce industrie du medef des
organisations d'acteurs économiques pour
expliquer ce que nous faisions et
quelles étaient nos objectifs
enfin pour ce qui concerne le premier
tronçon qui va partir en enquête
publique si vous avez la carte dont vous
vous avez cette immense rocade rouge
vous avez un tronçon au sud entre pont
de sèvres c'est à dire boulogne et noisy
champs sur marne à l'est qui fait 33 km
16 gares ce premier tronçon qui va
partir en enquête publique a fait
l'objet d'une concertation renforcée au
moyen de vingt-et-une réunion publique
que j'ai présidé avec pierre-alain
japonais dans toutes les communes
concernées par l'arrivée d'une gare
entre le 15 septembre et le 15 novembre
nous avons eu en moyenne 300 personnes
par réunion donc un formidable
engouement nos concitoyens qui sont
venus voir où en était le projet et
surtout qui sont venus encore apporter
leur contribution parce que cette
concertation avait pour objectif de
pouvoir faire encore évoluer le projet
là où il pouvait encore évoluer je
pourrais vous en dire plus si vous
voulez notre prochaine étape c'est bien
évidemment l'enquète public le dossier
d' enquête publique conformément au
planning annoncé en début d'année a été
transmis au préfet de région
fin juillet la ministre en charge de
l'égalité des territoires madame duflot
notre ministre là a saisi l'autorité
environnementale qui a émis un avis le
24 octobre
nous prenons en considération
les observations et les recommandations
des différentes personnalités organismes
consultés dont l'autorité
environnementale et donc nous mettons la
dernière main au dossier d'enquêté
publique les acquisitions foncières
c'est un processus industriel ne veut en
acquérir 5500 parcelles pour l'ensemble
du projet dont 90% en tréfonds et vous
savez que en droit français ce sont les
propriétaires de la surface qui sont
propriétaires des traits font ça veut
dire que lorsque l'on veut acquérir une
partie de terrain entre -15 et -49
puisque nos gars seront en moyenne à
moins de cinq mètres de profondeur eh
bien nous devons avoir naturellement un
acte notarié
un prix qui est validée sous le contrôle
de france domaine et imaginez lorsque
vous avez un immeuble collectif avec le
plusieurs dizaines de copropriétaires et
bien le tréfonds doit faire l'objet de
la signature de chacun des
copropriétaires nous avons donc choisi
un premier opérateur pour le tronçon de
ligne rouge sud qui concerne 1800
parcelles et 2012 et surtout 2013 vont
être sondés années de montée en
puissance des acquisitions foncières
absolument indispensable vous vous en
doutez bien nous souhaitons acquérir
principalement à l'amiable mais si nous
n'arrivons pas à discuter peut arriver
quand certains corps n'y arrive pas vous
connaissez bien mesdames et messieurs
les élus ces problématiques
nous oeuvrons à ce moment là à voir la
déclaration d'utilité publique qui nous
permettra d'exproprier les acquisitions
foncières donc c'est un point très très
important pour ce qui concerne les coûts
du projet le la mission que la ministre
a confié à monsieur auzanais fera un
point sur l'ensemble des coûts du projet
pour ce qui concerne ce qui est de la
maîtrise d'ouvragé société du grand
paris à mettrait à périmètre constant
par rapport à l'accord état région de
en sortie des études préliminaires nous
avons une augmentation de 2 et demi pour
cent je dis bien à périmètre constant
pour ce qui concerne ce qu'ils ont
enduré paris nous avons eu une
augmentation de 2 10% par rapport au
montant de ce qui est indiqué dans
l'accord
est à région donc nous avons pour
objectif de faire en sorte que les
délais et les coûts puis cette tenue au
maximum alors 2013
quelles sont les perspectives en 2013 le
conseil de surveillance a voté le 5
juillet dernier à la demande de la
ministre a voté la décision d'engager
les enquêtes publiques de façon
échelonnée sur l'ensemble des tronçons
et donc 2013 devra être une année où les
enquêtes publiques vont pouvoir monter
en puissance bien évidemment sur le
premier tronçon temps pour deux sèvres
et noisy champs mais également sur les
autres tronçons tout ça dépendra des
décisions que prendra le gouvernement en
matière de priorité de réalisation de
cet investissement
madame la ministre de l'égalité des
territoires nous avait fixé trois
objectifs le 26 juin dernier lorsqu'elle
avait inauguré l'exposition sur la
structure le design égard une exerce
deux priorités tout ne pourra pas se
faire tout de suite ni en même temps une
exigence de proximité pour répondre à
l'urgence au quotidien et aux besoins
des habitants et enfin une exigence
d'efficacité et pour répondre à ces
trois et six ans et sigean ce pardon la
ministre a confié donc à mission
technique à monsieur auzanais pour faire
le point sur les coûts globaux du grand
paris express puisque nous ne sommes pas
les seuls à intervenir dans ce grand
paris dans ce grand paris express
et pour faire le pour formuler des
propositions de priorisation ce rapport
doit être remis de façon incessante et
le premier ministre a indiqué le 30
octobre dernier que le gouvernement
disposerait de tous les éléments pour
décider début 2013 nous avons eu le 23
novembre dernier c'est très récent un
conseil de surveillance qui a validé à
l'unité à l'unanimité par dont le projet
de budget 2013 qui repose à ce stade sur
les hypothèses suivantes donc
l'activation des marchés de maîtrise
d'oeuvre c'est à dire les études
d'avant-projet sur le tronçon pont de
sèvres d'antichambre aline rouge sud
les acquisitions foncières qui se
poursuivent à limiter à ce premier
tronçon
la réalisation d' enquêtes publiques
supplémentaires en 2013
et tout ça pour l'instant à effectif
permanent puisque la cité du grand paris
talent et allusion publique de l'état
industriel et commercial sous plafond
d'emploi de l'état et en 2012 comme en
2013 nous avons droit pour l'instant à
100 5 équivalents temps plein le budget
fait apparaître également 2013 un effort
très significatif de subventions de la
part de la cité du gant paris à des
projets qui ne sont pas sous la maîtrise
d'ouvragé
je pense à la prolongation prolongement
de la ligne 14 entre saint-lazare et
mairie de saint-ouen la ligne
automatique qui est sous maîtrise
d'ouvragé conjointe de la ratp et du
stif pour laquelle nous participons à
hauteur de 30%
nous participons également à
l'adaptation de ses stations de la ligne
14 qui existent cette fois ci entre
olympiades
est ce un hasard puisque pour augmenter
la capacité de la ligne
il faut que nous passions de 6 à 8
voitures pour accueillir un maximum de
voyageurs et des statures et la ligne 13
et pour passer de 6 à u voiture il faut
mettre aux normes les stations
existantes notamment au plan de la
sécurité
nous participons également à hauteur de
30% là c'est du grand paris en 2013
continuera également de subventionner
les études conduites sur la ligne orange
qui est sous maîtrise d'ouvragé du
syndicat des transports d'île de france
le stif
enfin nous poursuivrons la montée en
puissance des acquisitions foncières
c'est un poste de budget davet un
investissement très important
voilà ces quelques éléments pour vous
donner l'état d'avancement le seul
président madame la sénatrice et
messieurs les les sénateurs avec un
budget de 203 millions d'euros en 2013
la cité du grand paris donc un budget
qui est plus du double de celui de 2012
nous poursuivons donc notre montée en
puissance naturellement nous sommes à
lisa dans les starting blocks
en attendant les décisions du
gouvernement sur la suite des opérations
nous avons comme je vous disais fait
pour l'instant notre maximum pour tenir
nos engagements
et la question des moyens de la du grand
paris dépendra aussi des décisions qui
seront arrêtées par le gouvernement
je vous remercie votre attention merci
monsieur capo-canellas ce merci monsieur
le président je veux d'abord remercier
le président val d'avoir programmé cette
audition qui nous conduit à parler de ce
projet important que vous conduisez
monsieur le président le bio avec toute
l'équipe de la sgp première première
question d'abord bon sommes tous
suspendus
en tout cas les maires franciliens qui
sont concernés à au verdict que pourra
peut-être présenté le rapport aux années
et bien sûr les décisions
gouvernementales qui qui suivront je
vais laisser sujet de côté parce que à
part la spéculation aux renoncez pas en
dire grand chose je veux simplement
revenir d'abord sur la controverse du
milliard d'euros puisqu'il ya quelques
semaines on a appris que dans le cadre
de la programmation triennale le fameux
milliards attendus pour la gp n'était
pas à ce stade inscrit je souhaitais
c'est comme essayer de faire la part des
choses on peut ici voir dans quelle
mesure ce milliard et est nécessaire à
quelle échéance
vous avez des ressources des ressources
propres qui est qu'ils sont ont été
créés si j'ose dire par la loi qui sont
payés par les franciliens
est ce que ce niveau de recettes vous
permet malgré tout de minorer le
milliard qui nécessaire pour pouvoir
lever après l'emprunt et puis question
annexe
j'ai bien compris qu'un certain nombre
d'organismes voisin voyez cette
trésorerie un peu opulente la première
année avec une forme dans vie donc y at
il ou pas de ce côté là des hypothèses
d'utilisation entre temps deux parce que
votre situation est paradoxale vous
aurez besoin de beaucoup d'argent mais
vous en avez peut-être un petit peu trop
tôt mais pas assez pour pour le plus
tard
les premiers sujets deuxième deuxième
point se pose là aussi la question de
l'intermodalité avec la ligne orange
vous avez évoqué ligne orange tout à
l'heure est-ce que là dessus il ya un
calage qui est qu'il fait est ce que ça
conduira à des hypothèses techniques qui
peuvent interférer sur la temporalité de
la réalisation de vos tronçon puisque
c'est sur le principe toujours séduisant
d'essayer d'avoir une intermodalité
complète entre la ligne orange conduite
à priori par le stif et vous ah mais ça
peut poser aussi des problèmes
techniques et de haies et de délais
c'est prison doit être abordée la
dimension environnementale et la ville
haute autorité environnementale
on a compris lorsque cet avis a été
formulée qu'il y avait une réserve puis
moi alors je pas si cette réserve peut
être surmonté est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un mot c'est un aspect qui
compte notamment pour cette cette
commission dernier point vous avez parlé
des gares tout à l'heure j'ai vu alors
tout ma casquette d'élu local que vous
aviez lancé effectivement des appels
d'offres en tout cas des consultations
pour des maîtrises d'oeuvre sur sega
comment pensez vous associer les
collectivités sur ce point à ce qu'un
travail partenarial qui marche bien avec
les gp mais sur ce point particulier
pour le moment il n'y a pas encore une
association très clair à me semble-t-il
des collectivités ce que je pense que
l'insertion de la gare dans son univers
va être un sujet central voilà merci
série de questions michel teston merci
monsieur le président sur le président
guillou en amour de l'examen par le
sénat du projet de loi sur le grand
paris
j'avais terminé à faire partie d'un
groupe de travail qui avait effectué un
certain nombre d'auditions et le
provincial que je suis donc à participer
à ces auditions probablement parce que
mon groupe avait souhaité que je puisse
éventuellement questionner les personnes
que le groupe de travail entendait sur
des questions relatives au transport et
plus particulièrement au transport
ferroviaire
alors je me souviens avoir insisté
particulièrement sur l'absolue nécessité
à mons à ce qu'il y ait une bonne
finalement connexion entre ce futur
réseau et les réseaux existants que ce
soit le réseau à grande vitesse actuelle
et future
le réseau transilien le réseau de métro
le réseau de tramway et on a bien pu
constater au cours de ses auditions qu'
il y avait un certain nombre de points
sur lesquels cette interconnexion
n'était pas totalement assurée donc avez
vous avancé sur la question parce que ça
me paraît important et ça paraît
important a beaucoup et puis même si
c'est pas finalement la finalité de du
réseau donc du grand paris j'avais
également fait apparaître mon étonnement
qu'on n'est pas pris en compte pour la
desserte de paris du fret ferroviaire
parce que qui est dit finalement
desserte de paris
c'est bien sûr essentiellement la
desserte voyageurs mais c'est aussi
l'intérêt qu'il ya à faire en sorte que
n'arrive pas à paris et dans la
périphérie parisienne des finalement
quantités considérables de camions alors
qu'on a des lignes ferroviaires qui
peuvent être utilisés au mieux donc là
aussi est ce que cet aspect qui n'est
pas au départ l'objet de ce projet nous
n'ont pas aussi être pris en compte si
alors charles revêt oui merci aux
serrures ce président on a une belle
carte
je suis tenté de vous poser comme
première question jusqu'où va votre
périmètre de responsabilité dans ce
domaine du projet dans paris dont on a
beaucoup parlé
non il y avait lié à ça l'interconnexion
avec je pense au grand port maritime du
havre puisque rond l'idée c'était de
faire du du grand port maritime du havre
le port de paris l'ouverture du de paris
vers le lotions et bien entendu de la
ligne grande vitesse paris normandie
alors comment ça s'inscrit dans cette
démarche parce que j'entends bien que il
faut donner un peu d'air à sion aux
transports parisiens et je crois que
c'est indispensable on voit bien pour
qui vient dans la capitale mais l'idée
aussi c'est de voir à travers la
nouvelle organisation comment il pouvait
y avoir une interconnexion y compris
dans le domaine du fret ferroviaire et
donc comment ça s'inscrit dans cette
démarche
est ce que dans votre permettent de
responsabilité ces aspects là sont
encore en vigueur
où en est-on parmi les grands projets
qui étaient prévues dans le cadre du
projet grand paris
car si francis grignon
merci enfin bon moi je suis pas parisien
donc je vois ça un peu de loin mais bref
j'aurais voulu quelques-uns oui quelques
petites explications quand même sur sur
la généralité du projet j'observe que
c'est c'est rond vert enfin ces circuits
vert et rouge font qu'on développe une
une partie qui est thales nord de paris
avait surtout s nord est puis sud ouest
et y à rien par exemple le nord-ouest
syrien
je voulais savoir ce qui avait présidé à
ça c'est tout vraiment je m'informe vous
avez parlé des délais imaginons que
toutes les décisions politiques soient
là et que l'argent soit là ne serait ce
que pour la première tranche que vous
avez décrite entre pont de sèvres et
noisy ça serait ça sera opérationnel
qu'en
la deuxième question la troisième aussi
un peu général est ce que ça a été pensé
ça pour un jour accueillir les jeux
olympiques et la dernière plus local
j'étais gf
le tgv est moi puisque je viens d'alsace
comme monsieur le maire de strasbourg
qui est là est ce qu'il s'arrête a bondi
à partir de bondy pas révolte qui ont
une intermodalité pour bâle et ailleurs
dans paris et pas pénétrer dans paris
par exemple 1 c'est la question
d'intermodalité au sens large comme le
disait notre collègue testons et en
particulier aussi pour le vrai être bien
sûr merci
evelyne dit dieu merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président dit
pouvez vous nous dire s'il y a en
complémentarité de ce travail une
réflexion sur les aires de stationnement
pour désengorger paris en termes de
véhicules
d'accord alors en réponse à aux
sénateurs capo-canellas sur la question
du du milliard d'euros moi moi c'est ce
que j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises dans
les réunions publiques les déclarations
à la fois de madame duflot et du premier
ministre notamment le 30 octobre dernier
à la manifestation à laquelle il était
sur l'avenir de saclay sont tout à fait
rassurante puisque le premier ministre a
dit sur la base donc de la remise à plat
des coûts et puis des priorités qui
seront déterminés pour la mise en oeuvre
dans le temps du projet à l'objectif du
gouvernement étant de sécuriser les
financements
et bien si il y as besoin d'un milliard
d'euros de dotations en capital en 2015
ce milliard sera là donc moi j'estime
que en la matière nous avons une réponse
tout à fait rassurant ce ce qu'on a fait
apparaître
ça rejoint votre autre question c'est
que nous sommes dans une situation un
peu paradoxale asta du grand paris
n'existait pas il ya deux ans en loi de
finances rectificative pour 2010 des
ressources fiscales dédiées ont été
créés et donc qui rentrait aujourd'hui
c'est vrai le rythme des dépenses est
encore inférieure au rythme des recettes
dans notre montée en puissance au rythme
actuel en fonction de ce que l'on a fait
depuis deux ans c'est en 2015 que
devraient disparaître ce fonds de
roulement et c'est donc en 2015 qu'il
est apparu à un besoin de ressources
complémentaires estimé à ce stade à un
milliard dans le schéma de financement
la cité du grand paris il fait surtout
du grand paris express
il y a plus de ressources il ya la
fiscalité via la dotation en capital
il y à l'emprunt est ce que nous nous
disons c'est qu'on peut tout à fait
imaginer que dans les années à venir
la dotation en capital et l'emprunt
interviennent de façon concomitante donc
c'est en fonction des priorités qui
seront arrêtées par le gouvernement qui
sera décidée d'après ce que j'ai compris
le montant de la dotation qui pourra
être être débloqués mais
le principe le semble-t-il en l'état qui
est la réponse du gouvernement ma
semblait tout à fait clair alors vous
disent vos clézio qui à juste titre que
le fonds de roulement aujourd'hui
suscite quelques convoitises
c'est vrai je comprends bien en même
temps c'est de l'argent qui n'est pas
inutile sergent qui est placé au trésor
nous avons l'obligation de déposer au
trésor qui ne nous rapporte rien
d'ailleurs mais qui permet j'allais dire
vas d'être rasées dans les caisses de
l'état et de d'alimenter les caisses de
les caisses de l'état
cet argent nous aurons besoin puisque le
fonds de roulement sera amené à
disparaître mais d'ores et déjà nous
avons voulu prendre en considération la
demande consistant à dire est-ce que
l'assaut du grand paris ne peut pas
intervenir sur des financements de
transport et c'est pour ça que nous
avons décidé lors du dernier conseil de
surveillance d'augmenter la
participation reste du grand paris pour
la première convention de financement de
la ligne 14 entre saint-lazare à mairie
de saint-ouen pour la première
convention de financement nous portons
la part de la sgp de 30 à 40 2 % mais
avec une obligation que nous a fixé les
temps
c'est que à la fin des travaux de la
ligne 14 à la dernière convention il
faudra que nous soyons revenus à notre
moyenne de 30%
celle qui est dans l'accord etat-région
donc pour l'instant nous faisons une
avance qu'il est de près de 20 millions
d'euros en chalet dire en aidant
deux départements la seine-saint-denis
et les hauts-de-seine dans le
financement de la ligne 14
ensuite vous avez évoqué les questions
de l'intermodalité ligne orange ligne
rouge c'est un sujet très important
puisque l'internaute l'inter opérabilité
exactement entre lagnieu ronger ligne
rouge c'est quoi c'est la possibilité
pour un train de la ligne rouge d'aller
sur la range et inversement
ce qui veut dire que en termes de
confort de transe mot pour les voyageurs
c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
efficace ce qui veut dire aussi que nous
sommes sur des infrastructures qui
devront avoir les mêmes dimensionnement
les même gabarit les médias m et même
arrêter rigolant et c'est naturellement
heureux c'est évident et c'est donc
l'objectif que nous a fixé le
gouvernement est ce qui a été décidé
c'est que y aurait déjà une première
intermodalité qui serait à champigny
donc nous travaillons actuellement avec
le stif nos collègues du stif sur les
différents scénarios d'intermodalité je
n'entre pas dans la technique mais vous
pouvez voir l'intermodalité à 6 voire
garacad voix à trois voies à deux voies
le coup n'est pas le même l'impact
travaux pour les communes concernées
n'est pas le même la dimensionnement des
infrastructures n'est pas la même donc
en terme mais aussi de confort pour les
usagers ce n'est pas la même chose donc
7 en fonction de ces différents critères
coût qualité pour l'usager impact de
travaux et délais de réalisation que les
décisions seront prises sur la ligne
orange
il est prévu que s'engage en début
d'année prochaine
une concertation un débat une
concertation à l'instar de celle qui
avait eu lieu sur les trois autres
lignes en septembre à partir de
septembre 2010 et naturellement c'est
après cette concertation est en liaison
avec nous que la meilleure
interopérabilité sera assurée à
champigny pour ce qui concerne l'avis de
l'autorité environnementale et les
réserves que cette instance a émises ces
les réserves portaient principalement
sur quatre points la question de
l'évacuation des déblais de chantier on
est sur plusieurs millions de mètres
cubes et nous avons élaboré un schéma
directeur des ventes évacuation des
déblais qui a été d'ailleurs transmis au
président du conseil régional dans le
cadre de l'élaboration du programme
régional le pré dec
pendant un peu barbare
nous avons eu également des observations
de l'autorité environnementale sur la
question de l'hydrologie et notamment du
rabattement des nappes mais aussi du
franchissement de la seine de la marne
des autres surfaces
dès que les observations aussi sur la
prise en compte de la nature géologique
les différents soldats l'impact
géologiques sur ces trois points là nous
apportons des éléments de réponse dès
très complet dans le cadre de nos
travaux en cours avant l' enquête
publique et puis l'autorité
environnementale avait fait une
observation en dix ans le dossier ces
4000 tâche c'est un énorme dossier il
faudrait c'est de le rendre plus lisible
plus maniable pour nos concitoyens
lorsqu'ils se rendront en mairie pour le
consulter au moins de l'enquète c'est
également une recommandation que nous
avons retenue est que nous allons donc
en simplifier la lecture vous évoquer la
question des gares et comment associer
les collectivités locales notamment au
choix dégâts nous avons effectivement un
coeur d'associer très étroitement les
élus locaux à l' architecture des gares
puisque je voudrais indiquer les gars
elles doivent à la fois témoigne de ce
cru dans un réseau avec des matériaux
des couleurs une signalétique immobilier
est également témoigner de ce que l'on
nous ayons des territoires qui ont leur
personnalité
lorsque les équipes vont être choisis
d'ingénierie et d'architectes elles ne
vont pas être qu'elles vont à ce
moment-là élaborer un projet et c'est au
stade de l'élaboration du projet que les
collectivités territoriales seront
associés moi j'y verrai personnes vous
savez à quel point je trouve que c'est
tout à fait essentiel voilà je crois que
j'ai à peu près répondu monsieur
sénateurs capo-canellas à vos à vos
questions je voudrais répondre à
monsieur testons concernant l'absolue
nécessité pour reprendre vos termes
monsieur le sénateur sur la connexion
entre le réseau futur ce nouveau réseau
primaire convard et créé le réseau
existant mais vous avez bien raison
c'est absolument fondamental et si on se
loupe est là dessus on n'aurait pas
réussi à ce moment là notre
notre projet est donc on a aujourd'hui
70% des gars qui sont en interconnexion
avec des motos lourdes rer transilien
métro parisien mais aussi des plus
légers tramway bus tout à l'heure je
recevais les représentants des taxis qui
me disaient mais alors comment comment
allez vous faire pour avoir des stations
de taxis dans vos gars c'est évidemment
quelque chose que l'on va prévoir
c'est pour ça qu'on a ces comités de
pilotage par gars qui s'est réuni ce
qu'ils comprennent non seulement la cité
du grand paris mais aussi les autres
opérateurs transport qui exploite les
réseaux le stif que l'autorité
organisatrice et les collectivités
parce que on regarde ça ensemble et nous
avons nous l'obligation d'un autre
projet d'assurer la bonne connexion avec
les les autres les autres réseaux alors
lorsque par exemple une gare nouvelle
est créée et bien il se peut qu'elle
soit menée a englobé la gare ratp où la
gare sncf sncf rff qui existe il se peut
aussi qu'en fonction des considérations
configuration du terrain on soit amené à
construire un autre bâtiment à côté du
premier la soie là il ya la question des
correspondances un des couloirs avec des
sujets financiers derrière qui donneront
la discussion entre les différents
opérateurs et nous mais nous avons lancé
les études confiées d'un côté rff
sincère de l'autre côté à la ratp
sur la question des ouvrages de
connexion assuré sur la réduction des
coûts ça représente il faut objectiver
tout ça et ensuite dire que la
discussion s'engage mais nous prenons
déjà très largement en charge des coûts
d'interconnexion dans le cadre de nos
études et dans le cadre de nos futurs
travaux vous avez évoqué la question du
fret ferroviaire
je comprend bien l'intérêt
la question mais c'est vrai que le métro
du grand paris ne sera pas un métro de
fret
on a fait le choix en toute connaissance
de cause puisque on sera à terme à un
métro avec un maître toutes les deux
minutes lorsque le schéma sera mise en
oeuvre
on ne peut pas assez raide et métros de
fret en revanche c'est vrai que dans nos
gares il faudra qu'on soit attentif à ce
que puisque on souhaite qu'il y ait des
commerces des services que ces gars
soient les centres de vie qu'il y ait la
possibilité pour les usagers
à ce moment là dit retirer un certain
nombre de commandes qu'il est impossible
d'assurer des livraisons mais
effectivement nous ne sommes pas sur la
problématique fret au sens fret sncf
pour répondre à monsieur le sénateur
revêt jusqu où va votre périmètre de
responsabilité la loi attribue du grand
paris une compétence d'attribution qui
concerne la création d'un nouveau réseau
de transport métro automatique
donc notre compétence ne concerne pas je
parle de façon rapprochée ni les rer
lignes et transilien et elle ne concerne
pas non plus la liaison avec le havre et
la ligne nouvelle paris-normandie
en revanche ce qui est important c'est
que l'organisation des ouvrages qui vont
accueillir les voyageurs soient
coordonnées quand on pense à nanterre à
nanterre où il y aura à la fois et hall
qui va arriver je pense en premier il y
aura la gare du grand paris express et
puis il est prévu de la gare la ligne
nouvelle paris-normandie naturellement
dans les scénarios l'étude menée à la
fois avec rff avec le sous l'autorité de
l'état la direction salle de la maison
du territoire puisque le le président
gouvernement avait confié une mission à
l'état de coordination entre des
différents opérateurs sur ce point nous
avons dans nos études nous calons les
scénarios de réalisation de ses
différents ouvrages et des espaces qui
ceux qui doivent être réservés mais nous
ne sommes pas compétents sur la ligne
nouvelle paris normandie et nous avons
déjà beaucoup à faire
avec le le métro du grand paris alors
pour répondre à monsieur le sénateur
grignon concernant la généralité du
projet vous disiez il n'y a rien rien au
nord-ouest alors le projet vous savez
qu'on a eu deux débat concomitant le
débat du projet porté par l'état
le réseau du grand paris le débat du
projet porté par la région qu'on
appelait arc express 4 modes débat ou au
cou au cours duquel les citoyens dans
leur grande sagesse et les habitants
nous ont dit mais mettez vous d'accord
avoir de projet c'est ne pas en avoir et
ce qui aboutit donc à un schéma
d'ensemble qui a évolué par rapport au
premier projet qu'avait naturellement
peut proposer à l'époque le ministre
blanc puisque on a on est passé de 39 à
57 gares pardon pour ce qui concerne la
la société du grand paris
on a augmenté le nombre de kilomètres de
façon importante sur la ligne verte par
exemple au départ sur l'univers qui
avait que quatre gars on est passé à
onze gars on a rajouté 9 km donc on a un
schéma d'ensemble qui est issu aussi des
contributions et des cahiers d'acteurs
qui ont été remis lors du débat et
l'objectif c'est à la fois d'être un
instrument de vie quotidienne en reliant
notamment les bassins d'emploi cadre
liant aussi et instrument de
développement économique reliant les
clusters donc quand on regarde les
différents clusters ile de france il y
en a huit
il y en a un qui n'est pas relié c'est
effectivement celui de confluence entre
la seine et l'oise au droit du port
d'achères mais là le rer e va être
prolongée jusque là danse est en projet
mais pour le reste les autres clusters
ce que ce soit le territoire de la
création à saint denis qui quoi qui
réunit les cieux du cinéma les écoles
d'artistes école du cirque que ce soit
la cité descartes à noisy champs la cité
de de la ville durable que ce soit le
plateau de saclay que ce soit la cité
financière de la défense que ce soit
l'aéronautique autour du bourget eh bien
ces différents clusters sont reliés
entre eux par le par le futur réseau
vous évoquer la question des délais tout
dépend bien sûr de la manière dont on va
continuer à avancer tout dépend aussi
des la priorisation qui sera arrêtée par
le gouvernement mais en tout cas pour ce
qui concerne précisément la lyre aux
chutes vous l'évoquiez entre
pont-de-sèvres et noisy-champs si les
choses se passent bien mais je suis
toujours prudent parce que sur un sujet
pareil on avance aussi en marchant quand
on voit l'ampleur de ce qu'il faut faire
et bien sûr nous prévoyons des premières
mises en service sur la ligne au sud fin
2018 et je l'aï surtout 2019 2020
donc on est sûr on ne mettra pas le ce
premier tronçon tout d'un coup un
service non prévoit quand même à ce
stade cette tunnelier c'est ce qu'on a
présenté en réunion publique
on a besoin de cette tunnelier si on
veut réussir à creuser à forer les
tunnels dans dans les délais donc avec
des départ des tunneliers on a
négocié tout ça avec les collectivités
territoriales c'est de la part d'une
commune c'est c'est quand même un geste
formidable de dire j'accepte un peu de
départ d'un studio parce que c'est une
emprise de chantier importante qui va
permettre d'avancer et nous avons réussi
à répartir ces puits de ses puits de
départ de tunisie et sur ce premier
tronçon sur la question des jeux
olympiques
c'est un sujet qui me dépassent très
largement hors fondement l'excusera ce
que le dire en tout cas c'est que on est
sur un métro à grande capacité
hormis la ligne verte parle d'un métro
adapté pour la ligne bleue pour la ligne
rouge et pour la ligne orange on est sur
des métros de 2000 personnes par am donc
destinée effectivement à a qu à pouvoir
accueillir et à monter en puissance et
un métro construit quand même pour des
décennies et je l'espère des siècles
vous avez évoqué bondi à la question
l'intermodalité tgv à ce stade je
je pense qu'il vaut mieux poser la
question à rff à la sncf ne défilent pas
mais je n'ai pas les éléments pour vous
répondre sur ce point et vous avez
évoqué madame didier la question du
stationnement et quelle complémentarité
au classement vous avez tout à fait
raison c'est un point très important
parce que je pense que nos concitoyens
pourrait nous reprocher de ne pas avoir
suffisamment anticipé cette question
alors il ya plusieurs
il ya plusieurs hypothèses et plusieurs
cas de figure nous nous inscrivons dans
le cadre du plan régional de
stationnement sous l'égide de la région
et du stif et l'objectif c'est quand
même en zone dense d'essayer d'éviter
que d'autres voitures se rendre vers la
zone dense en revanche en zones moins
denses l'objectif c'est de démultiplier
si possible les parcs relais de façon à
ce que les habitants laissent leur
voiture puisse savoir en termes de
tarification ça relève du stif mais
c'est ce que nous dit le stif puisse
avoir un dispositif de paiement du
parquet paiement du ticket de métro
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient conjoint
donc on aura des cas de figure très très
différents la première phase de
concertation la phase de concertation
renforcée sur la ligne rouge sud on est
très largement en zone dense fait
apparaître que dans la plupart des cas
les élus locaux ne souhaite pas que l'on
crée des parcs de stationnement
supplémentaires sauf lorsqu'on est en
zones non denses je pense à noisy champs
ou là ya véritablement une problématique
de parcs de stationnement
supplémentaires a créé que nous
prendrons en compte puisque c'est tout
l'arrivée des habitants de la seine et
marne qui va passer par là donc c'est
donc très très important donc là il y
aura une réponse très précise
je pense à sa mort sa mort là où sera
construite la gare eh bien il va falloir
détruire un parc de stationnement de
façon temporaire de 600 places mais nous
nous engageons à recréer ces 600 places
c'est bien naturel c'est comme lorsqu'on
sera amenés à déplacer une gare routière
parce qu'on crée une gare nous engageons
à recréer la gare routière est donc en
fonction des situations
on aura des parcs de stationnement où on
en aura pas mais tout sera fait on les
inclut stif pour que l'accès aux gares
du grand paris en zones denses soit
favorisé facilitée par les autres moyens
de transports collectifs existants voilà
à ce stade
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ce
que je souhaitais vous répondra long sur
v&o un petit compliment monsieur le
président j'entends bien que n'est pas
en responsabilité de la lgv vers la
normandie ou vers d'autres secteurs
régionaux mais je me souviens des deux
tous les échanges qui a eu lors de la
préparation du projet grand paris est
manifestement le fait que venant de
certaines régions il est l'obligation de
transiter par le coeur de paris et je
prends l'exemple d'un homme en dise
c'est à dire aller à gala à la gare
saint lazare pour ensuite aller prendre
une autre gare pour aller dans une autre
région contribue à alourdir la
circulation dans paris ça peut pas être
autrement d'ailleurs et donc mon
interrogation comment articuler vous le
fait que l'on puisse dans l'avenir en
sorte d'éviter cette pénétration dans
paris et que l'articulation sauf art
autour de la couronne parisienne
d'ailleurs qu'on a pu besoin si on va à
moi si si si je vais du havre demain le
jour où il y aura la lgv
à strasbourg on essaie déjà mais à
strasbourg ou ailleurs et bien puisse y
avoir le raccordement directement sur le
réseau général interrégionale merci
monsieur le président mes excuses
d'abord d'être arrivé en retard de ne
pas avoir pu voter l'exposé liminaire
mais j'ai quand même une ou deux
réflexions à faire même comme provencia
provincial parce qu'il ya certes des
différences entre les grandes villes de
province et l'agglomération parisienne
mais il ya aussi des ressemblances
il ya aussi des éléments et je vais
m'expliquer là dessus
moi je suis aujourd'hui convaincu que
nous sommes dans des systèmes de
complexité telle que on va de plus en
plus avoir de mal à gérer nos
fonctionnements j'ai rien contre la
société du grand paris mais elle vient
se juxtaposer s'additionner au stif à la
région aux communes aux départements à
toutes ces autorités qui sans doute ont
chacune leur justification
vous avez sûrement expliqué en
préliminaires mais le cheminement normal
à partir de là c'est de créer une
structure supplémentaire pour coordonner
tout ce qui existe et c'est sûrement pas
une bonne chose parce que franchement on
est là dans dans de la complexité ajouté
à de la complexité et nous plaidons
hogarth pour les villes de province pour
qu'il y ait une autorité organisatrice
de la mobilité durable à om d or je sais
pas si c'est applicable tel quel à la la
région parisienne c'est quoi une aot mdc
une autorité qui a la maîtrise de
l'ensemble de la boîte à outils qui
concerne la mobilité et même l'urbanisme
car tout ça va ensemble évidemment peut
pas raisonner uniquement sur la gestion
des flux existants il faut aussi résonné
sur le modèle de développement urbain
cela est lié à l'autre selon qu'on à tel
ou tel type de développement de modèles
si je puis dire de l'urbanisme eh bien
on aura une politique de mobilité et et
réciproquement
donc je crains que nous dirigions vers
des impasses redoutable à cause de cette
parcellisation de cette dispersion des
responsabilités alors même qu'il faut
être extrêmement cohérent madame didier
a parlé du problème du stationnement
elle a parfaitement raison le problème
du stationnement est absolument
déterminant sur le choix modal selon
sur surtout la localisation de l'offre
de stationnement on incitera ou pas les
gens à prendre les transports publics ou
le vélo ou que sais-je plus vous les
mettez en zone centrale dans ce plus ils
sont comment dirais-je rentable mais
moins ils sont pertinents en termes de
mobilité
c'est ça qui est ça qu il faut bien
comprendre si vous écoutez uniquement
les gestionnaires de parkings
ils vont tous vouloir mettre les
parkings au coeur de paris ou au coeur
de strasbourg où notre vie hors de mon
point de vue c'est une grave et donc
avoir les autorités qui supervise
ensemble qui y ont l'ensemble des
leviers permettant d'avoir une politique
globale et cohérente de mobilité est
très important à savoir la voirie à
savoir le transport public à savoir même
l'urbanisme à savoir les le vélo partagé
l'autopartage le stationnement
c'est extrêmement important et je crains
que aujourd'hui notamment en région
parisienne
on va se retrouver en difficulté
supplémentaire avec la création de la
société du grand paris et son rapport
avec par exemple le stif donc je vais
poser une question précise
est ce que vous pourriez aujourd'hui
nous dit comment vous fonctionnez
comment vous fonctionnerez avec le le
stif
lorsque vraiment vous aurez atteint
votre vitesse de croisière
je m'excuse mais moi je vous vois pas
très très clair ne serait-ce que sur ce
point précis mais la revendication
globale de la cohérence des politiques
publiques en matière de mobilité et donc
d'avoir eu dans le peut-être dans l'acte
iii de la décentralisation des réformes
qui sous prétexte de simplifier
complexifie j'aimerais bien qu'on
simplifie pour de bon ce qui est pas si
facile
capcom vous aviez oui merci au président
je crains d'illustrer un petit peu là la
remarque que roland burris roland ries
siens de faire l'instant je me souviens
d'avoir d'ailleurs évoqué le sujet
je crois que lors de l'audition de
guillaume pepy qui m'avait répondu que
si on passait du temps sur la question
institutionnelle sur la question du
mécano parce que c'est vrai que entre
ratp sncf rff le stif vous et d'autres
avec les collectivités et l'état qui
navigue au mieux s'est jamais simple en
ile de france c'est un peu ce que roland
sous-entendez c'est encore plus
compliqué qu'en province mais je vais
illustrer simplement sur une question
parce que vous l'avez ok monsieur
présentateur vous avez posé la question
des gars en dix ans il y à une évolution
du budget qui était de 2 et demi pour
cent par rapport à la prévision donc
tout va bien sur le projet global à toi
bien primés et par contre la question du
frottement entre les gares existantes et
les nouvelles gares comment on fait pour
que il y est bien là les fans qu on
dirait que les passages entre les deux
qui va payer ça j'ai compris que ce
n'était pas encore un sujet bien réglée
bon donc ma question c'est là dessus
qu'ils payent
y at il une clé aujourd'hui et puis
comment pensez-vous faire demain pour
qu'on arrive à avoir une salle gare une
gare objets uniques qui soit le lieu où
le voyageur va trouver ben le rer le
métro s'il passe par là le métro express
du grand paris la tangentielle si on est
vers chez moi
et une gare objet unique parce que c'est
avec chacun pose son infrastructure
chacun a sa signalétique quasiment
chacun a son mode de gestion et on c'est
vrai qu'il ya un petit d'épicés qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire une gare objets
objets de demain
moi j'ai envie d'y retourner presque
réfléchir sur la maîtrise d'ouvragé la
propriété est ce que il faut que les
gars en ile de france presse pour
présenter la sncf aux essentiels est-ce
qu'on peut pas réfléchir à autre chose
et je rejoins ce que vient déroulant
tout à l'heure c'est il faut concevoir
la mobilité comme tout on en rit ce a
oublié quelque chose en j'ai oublié
quelque chose là par rapport à ce qu'a
dit avant que je n'arrive michel teston
sur le fret
peut-être qu'il faut pas parler du fret
mais les livraisons
je pense qu'il faut pas écarter cette
question après moi je fais je préside
donc je copréside plus exactement un
club 10 du dernier kilomètre de
livraison et allouera pas trop long mais
il y à des villes pas en france mais
ailleurs où le tramway sert aussi à
faire des livraisons en milieu urbain
plutôt que d'avoir les camions qui
viennent au coeur des villes eh bien le
tramway alors soit avec des enr
accrochant des wagons spécifique ou
éventuellement à g spécifiques et en
dehors des heures de
de grande affluence on peut l'imaginer
donc je suis pas trop d'accord avec vous
lorsque vous dites a priori c'est pour
les voyageurs c'est pas pour les
livraisons
je reconnais que c'est un peu utopique
peut-être aujourd'hui mais il faut pas
l'écarter a priori ça existe dans
plusieurs villes d'europe
peut-être pas pour les métros mais pour
les tramways et essayons de ne pas
écarter a priori à ce stade où on est de
notre réflexion et les manques on
pourrait regretter par la suite
alors pour répondre à sénateur revêt
concernant la pénétration dans paris ou
éviter la pendaison dans paris quand
vous regardez la ligne nouvelle
paris-normandie son trajet il prévoit
l'arrivée avec une gare nanterre la
défense ou la donc vous tombez sur le
grand paris express notamment la ligne
rouge qui vous permet cette phase i/ii
d'aller où vous voulez en termes de
banlieue à banlieue et puis si vous
voulez vous rendre à paris vous étiez
vous continuez et vous arriverez à la
gare saint lazare qui va devenir
effectivement ce moment une gare tgv
elle n'était pas en vous partez du à
vous voulez aller prendre l'avion à orly
vous faites le havre salle à saint
lazare et là vous tombez sur la ligne 14
double et vous serez à saint lazare
en plus de trente minutes à orly un but
de 30 minutes
donc on n'oblige pas vous avez raison on
n'oblige pas les voyageurs à passer par
la zone centrale
puisqu'ils pourront rencontrer les
lignes du grand paris express avant pour
ce qui concerne les observations il
était la question posée par le seul
sénateur rice sur l'articulation stif
sgp je poserai juste rappeler ce que dit
la loi la loi elle dit la sté du grand
paris son premier objet c'est de
construire un nouveau métro n'ont qu'à
l'est pas du tout autorités
organisatrices pas du tout la prétention
de l'être les pattes elle ce n'est pas
elle qui va choisir laisse prétend ce
n'est pas elle est pas elle qui
déterminera l'offre de transport ni les
horaires ça c'est le stif donc il ya une
répartition des rôles nous nous
construisons on est très à fera en fait
si vous voulez on construit gare tunnel
site de maintenance
on peut être aménageurs si l'état et les
collectivités dans le cadre des
notamment des contrats de laurent théry
talent donc ces instruments de cohérence
entre l'état et les collectivités je
pense que la cohérence que vous appelez
de vos voeux aussi le souhaite mais ça
n'est pas du tout une obligation notre
coeur de métier c'est construire un
nouveau réseau
c'est la ratp qui sera de parloir
gestionnaire de l'infrastructure comme
aujourd'hui est bien entre l'aref sncf
gestionnaire dhafra et puis le stif
c'est l'autorité organisatrice avec
toutes les prérogatives de l'autorité
organisatrice
et quand par exemple sur la
détermination de l'emplacement d'une
gare le stif on dit il faut lui mettre
la gare à tel endroit et la rapprocher
parce que vous êtes vous améliorez la
correspondance avec le rer ou la ligne
de métro parisien hier il a tout son
poids pour donner ça le stif parce qu'en
tant qu'autorité organisatrice on fait
très attention à ce qu'il dit à la
question qu'on peut que je suis
conscient que le paysage est compliqué
quand on se pose la question du qui fait
quoi cela peut paraître compliqué quelle
est la question suivante que je pose
c'est est ce que on avance et est ce que
ça fonctionne je ne parle que pour ma
paroisse par pardonnez-moi l'asie gpl
n'existait pas il ya deux ans
aujourd'hui on est à la veille de la
première enquête publique et nous avons
avancé tambour battant et nous avons
avancé pas avancer tout seul ça n'est
pas possible on ne peut pas mener un tel
projet seul on ne peut le faire qu'en
étroite concertation avec les
collectivités c'est fondamental mais
avec les opérateurs et j'en veux pour
preuve que les vingt-et-une rayon public
que l'on n'a organisé sur la ligne rouge
sud nous et nous avions dans la salle
non seulement le public les élus très
présent mais le stif la ratp sncf rff et
nous nous avons préparé ces réunions
ensemble il ya eu des questions qui
portaient aussi bien sur
l'infrastructure nouvelle a créé que sur
le fonctionnement actuel des erreurs ou
des métros avec une entente extrêmement
positive et je crois je vous invite à
penser c'est vrai mais de la part de nos
concitoyens qui étaient présents le
sentiment qu'il y avait des pouvoirs
publics qui fonctionnait ensemble et
pierre serne qui est le vice président
du conseil régional
10 raisons du siphon chargé de transport
est intervenu plusieurs fois dans ses
réunions publiques en disant écoutez on
y lit à un accord entre l'état et la
région et les départements et les choses
avancent et nous avons montré je crois
le le image d'opérateur de transport
unis et qu'ils travaillaient ensemble
moi ce que je on peut sans doute
toujours améliorer les sources de dire
je n'ai aucun doute là dessus
mais aujourd'hui ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on avance et je crois que c'est
ce que s'y attendre nos nos concitoyens
madame duflot z exprimée le 26 juin
lorsqu'elle a inauguré l'exposition sur
les gars l architecture des gares en dix
ans la question la gouvernance c'est une
question qui viendra en temps voulu il
ya eu notre décentralisation qui va
arriver il ya des choses qui me
dépassent
mais dans l'immédiat elle appelait de
ses voeux
l'efficacité pour que pour que l'on
puisse avancer alors genre j'en reviens
à la halle haas et à la question
concernant le seul sénateur concernant
les coûts d'interconnexion et cetera
quand je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
à périmètre constant bref j'ai bien
insisté là dessus par rapport à ce qui
est dans l'accord état région et ce qui
nous est confiée dans l'accord
etat-région nous étions à 10% dans
l'accord état région et dès le départ on
sait qu'il y a la question du
financement de l'impact de l'arrivée du
grand paris express et des gars du grand
paris express sur les réseaux existants
en clair la création d'une nouvelle gare
du grand paris express va peut amener
des flux de voyageurs qui vont changer
se rendre une station ratp ou une gare
sncf rff et de ce point de vue là il
faudra peut-être à ce moment-là revoir
la dimension de la gare ou de la station
ratp les couloirs pour des raisons de
sécurité ou autre et là effectivement il
ya un sujet financier que nous avons
encore devant nous sur lequel comme je
l'indiquais tout à l'heure nous avons
diligenté l'ensemble des études qu'on a
confié d'ailleurs à la ratp rff sncf on
les avec le stif et pour lesquels nous
avons devant nous à engager les
discussions sur ce sur la répartition
financière
du qui paie quoi mais ce qui est très
important et c'est l'objectif que l'on
doit se fixer pour les voyageurs pour
les habitants c'est que le jour où le
grand paris express va arriver c'est que
les voyageurs n'est pas à subir de
désagréments parce que la gare sncf de
la station ratp n'aura pas été
redimensionné comme contenu donc on a
ligne par ligne
gare par gare et nous avons engagé ce
travail bien évidemment un point très
précis à faire
combien ça coûte qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire et comment se répartit les
financements moi j'ai toujours dit j'ai
pas de choses contrôle de l'autre de mes
tuteurs que j'étais pas fermé à ce que
l'on ait discussion avec sur les plans
financier avec les autres opérateurs
mais dire c'est un montant qui est
estimé qu'ils étaient par rapport à
l'ensemble des coûts du projet si vous
voulez c'est un on est pas on n'est pas
dans des milliards et des milliards
d'euros donc ce disque est très
important c'est d'abord déjà
d'objectiver la situation comment à
n'avoir qu'une seule gare vous évoquez
aussi mais ça dépend des situations
encore une fois il ya des moments où on
devra reconstruire une nouvelle gare
parce que l'arrivée du grand paris
express va nous conduire en accord avec
la sncf ou la ratp rff à refaire une
nouvelle gare que nous prendrons un
autre chardon qui aura une gare nouvelle
avec une unité de signalétique de
mobilier here on va s'entendre là-dessus
à dire on travaille tous les jours
ensemble donc l'entente n'est pas
mauvaise du tout loin s'en fout et puis
comme je les ai dit non non on ne pourra
pas avoir d' une seule gare parce que le
terrain tel qu'il est ne permet pas de
refaire une garnick et à ce moment là il
pourra y avoir une émergence nouvelle
est la question fondamentale ça sera le
lien avec la gare sncf ou ratp
existantes
mais ces gars elles vont elles vont être
contigu
lorsqu'on a présenté en réunion publique
puisque 22 communes sont concernées par
le premier tronçon d'aline sud
on a présenté à chaque fois la manière
dont la nouvelle gare où la nouvelle
allait créer où elle est englobée
l'autre comment allait se faire les
circulations des trains de la gare les
ascenseurs les escalators les mezzanines
les châles les salles des changes le
temps de correspondance donc tout ça se
fait et pour l'avenir aux chutes tout ça
est prêt oui ce que veut dire et les
questions qu'on a eu de la part de nos
d'été du public qui était là était
plutôt à la fois des questions très
pratiques et techniques combien de temps
je vais m et puis on a en a toujours
indiqué si vous voyez dans le
présentation que s'il semble qu'il
faille encore ajouter des batteries
d'ascenseurs et d'escalators et c'est
une sortie nouvelle une entrée nous vers
la gare ce sont des sujets qui peuvent
encore évoluer
mais nous n'avons pas eu de remarques en
disant mais votre système est absurde
parce que nous avons calé c'est
l'arrivée de notre infrastructure par
rapport à l'existant et que l'enjeu
fondamental c'est la qualité de la
correspondance bien je pense que wes à
vous remercier monsieur blanc pour ce
témoin qui venait de cette 7e accepté ce
jeu des questions et dayraut question et
puis parfois on nous avait encore
enrichie sur sur ce projet je pense
qu'on est tous conscients que c'est un
projet très important non seulement pour
paris mais aussi pour le reste de la
france
et c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
percevoir parce qu'en fait la question
de charles revêt on a bien vu que y
compris non pour ceux qui devront
traverser paris où nous rendons sur des
infrastructures telles que les aéroports
elle ce projet va faire respirer un
petit peu et je pense qu'il va aussi
faire de notre capitale aussi un atout
important pour l'ensemble du pays
c'est cet enjeu est aussi considérable
monsieur le préfet vous souhaitez dans
l'hôtellerie j'ai oublié de répondre à
monsieur à monsieur brice et je pris mon
excuse et concernant le fret
c'est vrai qu'il y a des expériences
menées sur les tramways tramway qui sont
un instrument
j'allais dire différent du métro en ce
sens que comme je lé indiqué tout à
l'heure il n'ya pas de parti pris contre
au départ moi je si dans le meilleur des
mondes on arrivait à la fois à faire
circuler des métros de fret et des
métros de voyageurs au fond de moi j'ai
pas d'obstacle intellectuelle on conçoit
l'intérêt d'une telle proposition
la difficulté est là c'est quand on
consulte les différents opérateurs et
quand on regarde la complexité parfois
que c'est de mélanger des sillons fret
et des sillons voyageurs ou des sillons
rer d sion tgv des cimes fret conduite à
des difficultés de fonctionnement
lorsque l'on a ras le schéma d'ensemble
réaliser on sera effectivement il
fréquence de métro à peu près toutes les
deux minutes et un oui oui oui mesdames
et en heure de pointe ont désormais
jusqu'à 85 secondes pour certaines
lorsque par exemple qu'on aura la
connexion ligne bleue ligne rouge à
saint denis pleyel vous sortirez de la
ligne d'eau de la ligne rouge vous aurez
sur le cac en face le métro avec toutes
les 80 secondes en heure de pointe la
difficulté c'est effectivement d'insérer
en dehors des heures de pointe
d'autres trains on pouvait également se
poser la question est ce que ça veut pas
se faire la nuit mais la nuit on va être
sur un métro automatique et la nuit
aujourd'hui tel qu'on l'a pu le voir
avec les opérateurs existants ayant les
uns le stif on est sur l'idée qu'il faut
aussi utiliser les plages denis pour
entretenir l'infrastructure et pour que
le gestionnaire d'un fracas sera la ratp
que l'exploitant pour ce qui sera sa
responsabilité puisqu'ils ont chacun
aura des sites de maintenant on sert à
l'issue d'intenses batailles roulant
site de maintenance industrielle puisse
occuper ces temps là pour entretenir
dans l'intérêt des voyageurs
donc à ce stade c'est vrai
la décision n'a pas été prise de prévoir
l'introduction de deux trains de fret de
métro de fret dans le dispositif mais
quand on regarde on peut la ligne rouge
elle fait 100 km nous n'aurons pas des
métros qui vont faire le tour de la
ligne rouge tout le temps parce que pour
des raisons d'exploitation de qualité de
service vous êtes obligés d'avoir des
terminus intermédiaires on va te noisy
champs prévois internet intermédiaire ce
qui est sinon si vous avez une ligne
trop longue ça ne marche pas plus vous
avez une ligne longue avec un nombre
d'arrêts importants
plus vous risquez d'avoir des
difficultés techniques notamment lors
des arrêts en gare
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que la ligne
bleue au départ qui partait de orly dans
le projet de monsieur blanc partie de
orly elle remonter jusqu'à roissy pour
ça que la décision était prise de la
coupe et hassan plein ce qu'on aura une
ligne directe de 55 km sur teknologik ne
qui aurait sans doute conduit à des
difficultés de fonctionnement donc déjà
en soit il faudra que l'on soit le
capable d'assurer un service maximale
pour les pour les voyageurs
le risque d'introduire des métros de
fret avec la logique que on est on est
sûr de la vitesse aussi on est à
tramayes pas beaucoup moins vite on est
sûr de là on est sûr de la vitesse avec
ce qu'on sera à 60 km de vitesse
commerciale en moyenne avec des pointes
jusqu'à 110 nous n'avons pas
effectivement voulu prendre ce risque
voilà en capacité de répondre
techniquement je joue ça me manque
enfin je veux rien je suggère que on ne
n'écarte pas a priori
voilà donc c'est tout parce que ça
existe pour le tram il n'y a pas de
raison enfin à mon avis les difficultés
d'insertion en certaine heure du jour ou
de la nuit
ça ne va peut-être pas être
insurmontable mais je dis peut-être
voilà donc c'est tout ce que je vous le
dis j'avoue
j'avoue mon humilité aussi sur la
question je pense que c'est que ce sont
des points qu'il faudra revoir avec les
exploitants là ça sera aussi à
l'autorité organisatrice l'a22 de voir
ce qui doit être fait puisque c'est elle
qui choisira les exploitants mais je
rebondis sur un point que vous avez
oublié votre tout à l'heure c'est le
fait d'avoir hangar des éléments des
conciergeries pour pouvoir retirer des
paquets que vous aurez pu commander le
fait d'avoir donc des zones de livraison
pour assurer ses livraisons en gare ça
c'est tout à fait prévu ça fait partie
des schémas sur lesquels on travaille de
façon à ce que la gare elles servent non
seulement aux voyageurs mais qu'elle
soit aussi un endroit pour les habitants
li également au commerce
il faut que si on a des commerces sur
les zones de livraison pour alimenter
tout ça il faudra qu'on puisse avoir les
horizons pour déposer les paquets que
viendront chercher les habitants qui ont
fait leur commande sur internet ecsta ça
c'est tout à fait prévient ronge
quand on a vu venise tout est permis
il faut bien approvisionné c'est cadeau
faire office de transport fret comme et
c'est vrai que c'est une question
importante dont je crois que c'est une
question est ce que vous dites je ne
balaie pas les choses et un revers de
main je voulais raconter des anecdotes
là dessus quand je les gens raconter un
jour lorsque je suis devenu président de
la compagnie des transports
strasbourgeois ça remonte à pas mal
d'années c'était en 1989 j'ai découvert
avec stupeur que un des actionnaires de
la compagnie c'était une société
d'économie mixte était une entreprise
qui étaient les sucrerie d'erstein et je
me suis dit qu'est ce que les sucrerie
d'erstein qui produisent du sucre
évidemment vienne vient de faire dans le
capital d'une société de transport j'ai
compris pourquoi c'est parce qu'à une
certaine époque dans l'antre le guay ont
transporté les betteraves du kochersberg
à l'ouest de strasbourg jusqu'au sud de
strasbourg erstein en passant par les
voir urbaine le tramway donc enfin où
les wagons du tramway adapté à ça voilà
la raison pour laquelle ces sucreries et
est actionnaire
donc c'était bien lui fret bien lui
ferait ces mêmes même pas les livraisons
moi je suis surtout préoccupé
aujourd'hui faut être bien sûr mais par
la livraison en milieu urbain les
camions de 20 tonnes qui viennent au
coeur des villes qui encombrent tout le
monde et qui sont sur le mode rester
derrière moi moi je travaille ce que je
veux dire
bien merci encore merci
et puis bravo pour tout ce travail
accompli et puis la vision qu on l avait
donné de ce grand projet voilà pour
cette audition concernant le projet
d'aménagement des transports projet du
grand paris si vous souhaitez à la
revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très bonne fin de journée
à tous